and we begin this Sunday morning with
America's national security and the
threat of communist China as Secretary
of State Anthony blinken is now in
Beijing today for high-level diplomatic
talks with the Chinese Communist Party
blinken making the trip despite
increasing aggression from China toward
America including most recently as
surveillance spy balloon flying freely
over the continental United States
including hovering over military sites
and sending military secrets back to
Beijing in real time operating a spy
Base in Cuba to surveil the United
States and secret police stations across
the country while also harassing our
military in Asia and exploiting Biden's
wide open Southern border with
apprehensions of Chinese Nationals now
up 1300 percent in the last year all of
this after more confirmation this week
of what Arkansas Senator Tom Cotton told
us first on this program back in
February of 2020 that covid-19 likely
escaped from the Wuhan lab as
journalists Michael schellenberger and
Matt identified the first people
sickened with covid-19 symptoms who were
the scientists at the Wuhan Institute of
virology working on gain a function
research at the time in even worse the
U.S may have funded it all this week the
nonpartisan government accountability
office reports the U.S sent at least two
million dollars to fund several Chinese
research Labs between 2014 and 2021
including the Wuhan Institute which
oversaw the gain of function experiments
where it likely leaked and infected the
world joining me right now to talk about
all of that as the ranking member of the
Senate Homeland Security committee a man
who has been probing all of this from
the early days of coven the breakout
Kentucky Senator Rand Paul with me right
now Senator great to see you this
morning Happy Father's Day
thank you good morning let's talk about
all that we learned this week in the
face of this Anthony blinken trip first
off what are you expecting from the trip
by our secretary of state to Beijing
you know I think despite our differences
and despite the ratcheting up of
rhetoric I think diplomacy is important
and so all throughout the Cold War we
tried to have diplomacy with Russia we
should continue to have diplomacy with
China I think we should have ongoing
Arms Control talks even despite all of
the things and all the complaints look
I've had a lot of complaints about the
leak from the lab but there's a lot of
discussions and ongoing diplomacy that
needs to occur so I actually wish
blinking well and I'm glad he's making
the trip so tell us about the news this
week where these journalists have
identified the first people sickened in
the Wuhan lab those scientists obviously
are dead right now what are your
thoughts
this is a big deal this is an article by
Michael schellenberger and Matt taibi
and in it an Alan gutentag in the
article they revealed that the first
people to get sick from covid were three
scientists that they worked in the Wuhan
lab with the bat scientist Dr she in
fact one of them the one they think that
was the first scientist to get sick the
first person to get sick was one of the
ones creating these new viruses viruses
not found in nature this is the cane of
function research and so this
essentially closes the deal what I'm
going to try to pursue now is whoever
revealed this if there is documentation
of this it's all supposed to be
Declassified tomorrow and that
legislation passed unanimously if we can
get that Legend if we can get those
records and actually put it out there
for all the public to see that the first
person that got sick was a scientist at
the lab then it's a done deal we know it
came from the lab and everybody can just
admit it but then we can move to the
reform the reform is we shouldn't be
funding this kind of research in China
but we also shouldn't be funding this
kind of research in the United States
well I mean did we fund this did we fund
the beginnings of of this disease
yeah and I think we share responsibility
you know so I met with the Chinese
Embassy about a month ago and I asked
them for help on this and we have had
one person in China now the former head
of the CDC George gowell has admitted
that a lab leak is a possibility what I
would say to China if I were on the trip
with Lincoln is that there's a shared
responsibility the U.S government funded
this the US government advocates for
this and an accident happened if you'll
be forthcoming with us and let us know
that those scientists were the first to
get sick they have to know this by now
if they're forthcoming with it we could
move on in a Cooperative way because we
can't make China have rules on gain of
function although they have passed some
new rules in their country but what we
need is an international Consortium of
countries that will voluntarily agree to
restrict this the United States needs to
restrict this there are people
estimating that the next time this
happens the next time we have a leap
from a lab that between five and fifty
percent of the population could die from
another man-made virus so this is very
very serious this is up there with
nuclear arms control this is up there
with the danger of nuclear war but this
is much more Insidious it's harder to
trace but still millions of people can
die from a man man-made virus but we all
know that communist China covered it up
initially how are you going to get the
truth now they won't even allow an
investigation into the Wuhan lab
yeah it's not easy and they haven't been
forthcoming I think the only way to
convince them is that it won't all be
about blaming them because we
participated in funding this the blame
equally should go not only to Chinese
authorities but to Anthony fauci and all
those who advocated for this but there
has to be a reassessment look Bill Gates
has been over there recently Bill Gates
is the largest funder of trying to find
these viruses in remote caves and bring
them to big cities so what happened in
China is they went eight to ten hours
south of Wuhan two to three hundred feet
deep into a la into a cave found viruses
and took them back to a city of 15
million there are many many scientists
who think that Bill Gates is wrong and
funding this that our government's wrong
that the Chinese government that really
we don't need to be searching for
viruses that may never interact with man
and it's worse than that they bring
viruses that we may never interact with
they bring them back to the lab but then
they manipulate them by combining them
with other viruses to create viruses
that don't exist in nature but this is
law largely been funded by Bill Gates he
he funds The Who more than most
countries do so there's a responsibility
there and I don't think he's not I think
he's well intended but I think he's
inadvertently helped to create something
that the biggest danger to mankind right
now is something that he's been funding
and that is finding these viruses taking
them back to the lab and manipulating
them to make them more dangerous wow I
mean look we can talk about this now
freely but back in the early days and
the peak days of covid-19 God forbid you
said anything about any of this you were
canceled social media and and the
mainstream media wouldn't allow you to
push back on anything against China and
uh the the covid-19 uh originating there
what about Anthony fauci's
accountability and the media complicit
what we know is from the very first days
of the pandemic in January of 2020 that
Anthony fauci orchestrated a an
elaborate cover-up he knew there was a
problem at three in the morning he was
emailing somebody on January 31st that
person was head of the committee That
was supposed to review dangerous
research the p3co committee the
potential pandemic pathogens it was
supposed to look at this dangerous
research but a fauci allowed it to go
around that so he knew from the very
beginning Not only was he funding the
wu-on research but he was going around
the regulatory apparatus to let it
happen even though the rules said it
shouldn't have happened without more
scrutiny so he knew this from the
beginning and it was an active cover-up
he actively got papers placed that were
not valid papers into into large
scientific journals so yes there was a
cover-up from the very beginning but a
real judgment error and this is a man
Anthony fauci who said in 2012 that this
kind of research to create new virus was
so important that even if a pandemic
should take place that it'd be worth the
knowledge I think there are several
million people particularly a million
Americans who would question whether
that was good judgment or not so whether
or not he was um some you know poor
judgment or not it was incredibly bad
decision to fund This research yeah and
I know you're waiting on more
information after you sent the letter to
the head of the HHS honorable uh the
Javier Becerra will wait for uh when you
have more information as a result of
those letters Senator good to see you
this morning thanks very much
thank you Senate Homeland Security
ranking member Senator Rand Paul thank
you